today on the mat wall show the media is
in full panic pushing mode over omicron
uh we're told that this the winter of
death and misery is upon us but how
worried should we really be we'll talk
about that also joe manchin blocks
biden's agenda pope francis continues
his war against conservative catholics
and students in fairfax county protest a
hate crime that happened at one of the
schools but wait until you hear the
totally unexpected twist in that hate
crime story and finally in our daily
cancellation mark zuckerberg has
launched his virtual reality metaverse
as he calls it and the metaverse has
already had its first me too moment
we'll discuss all that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know as more and more companies are
falling all over themselves to appeal to
the left wouldn't it be nice to find one
that supports your values well here's
one for you charity mobile they're the
pro-life phone company they partner with
you to automatically support the
pro-life pro-family charity of your
choice with five percent of your monthly
plan price and they've sent millions of
dollars to charities so far and they're
gonna send millions more in the future
um and there are a lot of great perks as
well that you get with this product new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping when you mention offer
code walsh plus you get a free christmas
gift with every phone from charity
mobile while supplies last and if you're
worried about the hassle of switching
which don't worry about that charity
mobile makes it very easy to switch you
can keep your existing phone and phone
number and you may even be able to keep
your existing phone as well but if you
need a new phone there's no problem
there either charity mobile has a
variety of options from basic flip
phones and low-cost smartphones to the
latest 5g phones they also have safe um
phones flip phones that sort of thing
with parental controls if you want to
get a phone for your kid couldn't
recommend that highly enough so switch
to charity mobile and support the causes
you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh now that kovitt has been
picked up for a third season with the
promising new antagonist omnicorn taking
center stage the panic porn peddlers
have ramped up their fear-mongering to
levels not seen really since season one
a few days ago president joe biden
delivered his holiday greeting to
america by promising us a winter of
illness and death which sounds like a
line from a christmas carol that a goth
emo band might perform businesses across
the country are already preemptively
closing as we're warned that more
lockdowns might be coming in some
localities schools have already shifted
back to virtual learning though of
course virtual learning is a euphemism
for not learning anything at all
millions of kids have already fallen
behind academically while suffering
severe mental and emotional damage which
has led to unprecedented levels of
childhood suicide and self-harm
but the powers that be have decided that
not enough trauma has been inflicted on
the young let's they need even more
so nbc reports this it says prince
george's county in maryland on friday
became the first major school district
to announce that all students will
transition to remote learning as cases
surge
the shift to online learning will begin
monday four days before the start of
winter break and continue for two weeks
after school resumes on january 3rd
and then of course after those two weeks
are over they're going to say oh you
know we might as well just stick with
this until the end of the year
in
new york city the department of
education has closed 859 classrooms
quadruple the number of a month ago and
another nearly 2 500 were partially
closed as newly reported coven 19
affections rose sharply in the city in
upstate new york officials announced
that a suego city school district was
transitioning to remote learning from
friday until december 23rd because of
rising coveted cases with 60 cases since
last sunday and staffing shortages in
missouri on monday the south notaway
school board voted to cancel the rest of
the fall semester and resume on january
3rd after the winter break because of
district-wide shortages caused by
coveted cases and the saint roche
catholic school in st louis said it
would move to virtual classes this week
and return after the winter break
because too many students and teachers
are out sick now again you know caveat
on all that once again is that um
this is these are temporary measures and
we already know what happens with
temporary coven measures
um pretty soon temporary becomes a month
two months and then
i i i think for a lot of these schools
we're going to go to it's going to be
summer break we're going back to summer
break
and then well you know maybe in the fall
we'll see about opening schools again
meanwhile the director of the nih
francis collins has said that we could
be facing a million cases a day
thanks to omnicorn in the near future
now then again collins has apparently
lost his mind as he broke into song
shortly after saying this
[Music]
somewhere
past the
pandemic
when
we're
free
there's a
life i remember
full of activity
[Music]
sorry but i'm sure you understand that i
can't mention the name francis collins
on the show now without playing
part of that clip now luckily for you
he's retiring so there shouldn't be a
reason in the future to mention him
unless i come up with one which i'll try
dr liana wen former planned parenthood
head current cable news talking head was
singing her own sad song on cnn this
morning as she delivered instructions on
what you must do if you want to see your
family over the holiday here's uh dr
leanna when
your two out of three
rule for safe interactions doctor one
explain to people what that is
for people who are gathering indoors
over the holidays i would recommend at
this point when there's so much virus
around this that you have two out of the
three things vaccination testing or
masking so if you are fully vaccinated
and ideally boosted and you want to see
other people indoors without a mask
meaning maybe you want to have dinner
with them ideally everybody also gets
tested that same day with a rapid test
now i know that tests are hard to come
by in some parts of the country but
that's the ideals that you get tested if
you're going to be if nobody is
vaccinated or if there's some people
there who are unvaccinated if you're
getting together you should be masked
and you should be tested basically you
should have two out of three things
vaccination testing or masking at this
point with that much virus around us
really quickly in terms of testing as
you said it needs to be done that same
day so if you took a test let's say
christmas eve and you're meeting up with
people on christmas you were negative on
christmas eve doesn't mean you still are
a christmas day
that's exactly right the closer your
test is to when you're gathering with
people the better and i think this is
something that the buy administration
really needs to work on they've done so
well when it comes to vaccinations
that's great but they now need to put
the same amount of effort to increasing
access to testing why not mail test to
every american why not have to use the
uk or germany or so many other
approaches from around the world where
everybody is able to get tests testing
should not be the limiting factor
yeah why not why not test everyone well
there's a bunch of reasons
why not uh but we'll get to that in a
second fauci had a similar message on
abc cautioning americans that they're
permitted to celebrate christmas in his
magnanimous he will allow it under
certain circumstances
but they must not attend any gatherings
unless they've obtained the personal
medical records of everybody in
attendance beforehand
you said earlier this week that if
you're vaccinated you should feel
comfortable traveling and celebrating
the holidays with with your family
uh do you still believe that
no i do if you are vaccinated and
boosted and are prudent when you travel
when you're in an airport to be wearing
a mask all the time you have to be
wearing a mask on a plane
do not do things like go to gatherings
where there are people who you do not
know
what their vaccination status is
do not
that's he's not recommending this isn't
a suggestion
do not
faucing is of course still pretending
that the unvaccinated are the primary
drivers of covet transmission
but right now there's a coveted breakout
in the senate to include senators booker
and warren
there's a breakout in the nfl taking
dozens of players out of their games
this week and they had to rearrange a
bunch of games cancel some games there
are breakouts everywhere and often in
places where almost everyone is
vaccinated so the dirty little secret
which is not a secret at all
is that the vaccine does not prevent
transmission
this is an undeniable fact
but guys like fauci are not eager to
acknowledge it because if they did
then they would lose the moral high
ground over the dreaded unvaccinated
you know if the unvaccinated are simply
taking a risk with their own health
there's no reason to condemn them
there's no reason to be angry at them
just making their own decision
they make for unconvincing villains in
this story if their vaccination decision
is a mere personal matter but fauci and
company need
their villains and that's why they gloss
over the fact that vaccinated people are
also spreading covet
they're not going to change their
approach or messaging no matter what
we are going again into our third year
of covid
with they say record numbers of cases
and yet they say all the measures we've
taken to fight covet have totally worked
and we should keep doing the same thing
indefinitely
covett is worse than it's ever been they
say
but their recommendations for stopping
covet have absolutely worked and you
must not question those recommendations
cognitive dissonance is the real disease
here i would say
here's the other fact that they seem not
so eager to highlight
omnicorn according to the available data
is extremely extremely mild according to
the data
ben shapiro posted these graphs this
morning on his twitter which sum
everything up quite nicely i think
coveted data at a uk this is this is out
of the uk and in one graph you can see
uh cases spiking to a level that we
haven't seen all year that's a that's a
big scary spike in cases that you can
see on the graph
but then the other you can see deaths
hardly spiking at all
so the cases graph looks like a mountain
the death graph looks like a molehill
other data seems to show that
hospitalizations in south africa where
all this started with omnicorn dropped
by 90 percent
while the death rate for people who were
hospitalized dropped by 75 percent
again that's a that's a that's a 75
drop in deaths for hospitalized people
specifically
covid was already a mostly non-fatal
illness mostly
and even less fatal than the numbers
suggest listen to this report on
studyfinds.org this is from this morning
it says 4 in 10 coven 19 patients are
asymptomatic carriers of the virus
responsible for over 800 000 deaths in
the united states
researchers from china say a global
study of almost 30 million people
found silent cases of the virus are
twice as prevalent than previous
estimates feared
the results show 40.5 percent of the
confirmed cases of the illness are among
people who show no symptoms of the
infection at all
rates rose among certain groups
including pregnant women air and cruise
travelers and care home residents or
staff
now this is presented as a bad thing
but it underscores how mild covett has
been for millions of people not for
everybody but for millions
but it also means more importantly that
many millions more you know
many millions more certainly had covid
but they never counted as a case because
they never knew there was any reason to
get tested
this would mean that the actual
mortality rate for covid is
significantly lower than it appears
and omnicorn is 30 or 40 times less
lethal than that
this is all good news
even if it's presented to us like a
tragedy
well i should say good news relatively
speaking right the very low lethality of
kovid generally and omnicorn
specifically is good news given that
kovid was unleashed on us by china and
we now live in a world where it exists
like given that fact this is good news
in in relation to that
now the best possible news if we could
live in a world any world we wanted
would be for coveted to go away
and while we're in that fantasy land we
might as well snap our fingers and make
cancer disappear too and it could take
diabetes and arthritis and alzheimer's
along with it
that would be the best scenario right
i would very much prefer that
but unfortunately that's not on the menu
a world without covid is not an option
and will never be an option probably
thanks to china we exist in a reality
where kovid also exists
and will always exist
it's not ever going away
so just put that out of your mind
don't don't fantasize about a future
point where we no longer have to hear
about covid or worry about it
that's not going to happen
you know don't hold on to that hope
let go of the hope
throw it over a cliff
let it shatter on the rocks below
we will always live in a world with
covet
which means
that your personal coveted prevention
strategy
must be one that you can live with for
the rest of your life
if your personal covit prevention
strategy isn't something you can live
with for the rest of your life you need
a new strategy
because covid will be here forever
find a way to live with it
or let it ruin your life
those are your choices
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well if you're like me and you were born
into a world back in ancient times
before the internet took over our lives
and everything in our life was contained
just on the phone we carry around our
pocket um then uh if you're if you're
like me that means that you have all
many many memories from your childhood
contained on what are now antiquated
technologies like you know physical
pictures and vhs tapes and that sort of
thing
um and the problem with that is that uh
is that you where do you keep them in a
box somewhere where they can easily get
destroyed we've had flooding in our
basement before we've lost lots of uh of
um things that we cherish from our from
our childhood and that's why i have used
legacy box and i can't recommend it
highly enough it's a very easy to use
legacy box is the easiest and safest way
to reclaim all the priceless footage you
haven't seen in years you send in your
legacy box filled with aging vhs tapes
camcorder tapes film reels and pictures
their team of
professionals digitize everything by
hand at their uh huge production campus
right here in the usa and uh then they
just send it back to you it's really as
simple as that you put it in a box you
send it to them they take care of
everything they put that in a box and
send it back to you and now you're going
to have all of those priceless memories
in technology that is efficient that you
have access to anytime you need it and
it will also be safe from damage or
anything else with christmas just around
the corner there's there's still time to
buy the best christmas gift ever legacy
box visit legacybox.com walsh take
advantage of an exclusive discount for
listeners legacy boxes are still in
stock and ready to ship visit
legacybox.com walshford exclusive offer
that's legacybox.comwalsh
well we're still having christmas in my
house i don't know about uh fouchy or
you know anybody else
and uh hopefully you've got your
christmas shopping done um
all of my christmas shopping is done
because as i rave about every year and i
have to say it once again
is um
around the holidays especially it's it's
you know it's why i cannot recommend
marriage highly enough there are a lot
of reasons why i recommend marriage but
especially as a man
um
you know the holidays used to be pretty
stressful for me because i had to go out
and had to shop for all these people
and now that i have a wife she just does
she does all of that i don't have to do
any christmas shopping it's it's
tremendous
it's like a totally stress-free
environment for me
and and she enjoys it she likes shopping
for doing christmas shopping so it's
really it's a i i am blessing her by
you know giving her that chore to do you
know in a way really
um i just i'm assigned
like she does she buys gifts for
everybody
and so she buys 50 000 gifts
and then i'm assigned of course i buy a
gift for her so i do i do that um i
don't usually put her in charge of
buying her own gift but then she'll
assign me like a couple of people she'll
say oh can you just get that and then
and so this year i was assigned to get a
couple of things for um
for uh my oldest son
and so i've decided to get him
i went to bass pro shops
this uh this weekend and i got him a
pocket knife and a bb gun
so i'm getting them both
i i can't tell you that's the best
decision in the world but i i know he'll
enjoy it it'll be his best christmas
ever
you know and i i i've cause i've been
thinking about this do i want to get him
something like that for chris i think
he's old enough like he's responsible
enough you know when you when you when
you're i think it's good for a boy to
have a you know swiss army knife and a
bb gun
um
and i'm trying to convince convince
myself that was the right decision he's
responsible enough but then he does
things that make me second-guess it so i
you know i went i got him this stuff
and then yesterday we were outside and
he was climbing a tree
and he shouts to me says daddy could i
jump from here and i look up and i'm
like you're 40 feet up no you that's
you're just that's suicide
i'm thinking maybe the pocket knife
wasn't the best decision
he's gonna take that pocket knife daddy
can i stab myself in the eye
we'll see
but that's what happens when you put me
in charge of of buying the gifts i buy
dangerous objects and weapons that's
what i do
okay a couple other coveted related
items here um first of all we have de
blasio
very impressed with himself talking
about why
mandates are
great policies and they they really work
really well he says uh let's listen to
him
people want to lead their lives i mean
you know i feel it here in new york city
by the way i'm from philadelphia so it's
not like i i i live in a rural area um
but i feel it in every block that i walk
in new york city but if i were in the
middle part of the country with you i
don't think we'd see masks i don't think
we'd be showing our vax cards anywhere
so i come back to that point where
unless everybody's on the same page in
the country we're kind of screaming you
know how you get on the same page people
have to lead so look i believe with
enough leadership enough mandates we're
going to get a hell of a lot more people
vaccinated the more people vaccinated
the more we actually make the transition
to a time when covid is in the
background not the foreground and we
know these mandates work and we know
people respond look human beings are
pretty predictable if you say your
paycheck depends on it or your ability
to enjoy life and go do the things you
want to do people will make the
practical practical decision
overwhelmingly and they'll go get
vaccinated but we aren't pushing hard
enough we got to go farther yeah so de
blasio has discovered uh
the the secret here apparently if you
threaten people and you say i'll take
your livelihood away and i'll i'll take
away your ability to feed your family
and i'll make your kids starve if you
don't do as i say they'll do as you say
amazing
this is a what a what uh this guy's like
a it was he's an
expert in in human psychology
i guess we could say the same of uh of
you know a lot of the armed robbers who
many of them you could find in new york
city
what they they've they've made similar
discoveries which is that um you know
amazingly if they pull out a gun and
they put it to someone's head
and they say give me your money
most people will give the money because
they don't want to die
of course the but then there's that
leaves the the whole moral and ethical
question of
is it okay to manipulate people in that
way to coerce behavior in that way
is it okay to threaten to take people's
livelihood away because they're not
doing as you say
to treat them like criminals when
they're not criminals
to um
[Music]
coerce people into making medical
decisions
is that morally okay but of course for
him
morality has nothing to do with it and
also keep
notice something else that he said there
he said well we want to go from a point
where covid
is in the background
rather than the foreground
so they're not even pretending anymore
for the most part i mean yeah you have
francis collins singing about how uh
what one day when we're past the
pandemic like being over the rainbow but
of course that's that's like a mythical
place
so you still have a little bit of that
but most of these people are like de
blasio that if you listen to what
they're saying they're telling you this
it's it's never going away it's just
background or foreground
but background or foreground is relative
okay it's that all depends on where you
position yourself
what happens to be in the background
or in the foreground that depends on
where you are standing where you have
decided to position yourself
now a lot of us have been living
just as they they said in the beginning
of that clip
a lot of people are living in places
like in nashville here where i live
covett is very much in the background
far in the background
because that's how people have chosen to
live
it's in the foreground in new york
because people have chosen to live their
lives
staring at covid every single day and
talking about it
and they've they even decided to
incorporate it into their lives to that
extent
but that's a choice that has nothing to
do with with um
with covet itself per se
it's your choice how you decide you want
to react to it
and what i can tell you to reiterate the
point in the opening
if you ever want to live
with covid merely in the background
then that's a decision you have to make
in your own life
to live that way
and at this point part of that decision
might be you've got to move away from
places like new york
because in new york they're not going to
give you that option it's always going
to be in the foreground
so that in a way that's the right way of
putting it
of course he wants you to learn the
wrong lessons from that
it's background to foreground and uh and
but it is in the background you know it
it it will still be there and it's gonna
be in the background with a lot of other
terrible things
and there but there will come a time
when when the background becomes more of
the foreground for you if you get sick
with kovid now it's less of a background
thing
and when that happens you deal with it
cross that bridge when you come to it
related in a
president trump was interviewed on fox a
couple days ago
and he was asked a a question that i'm
i'm glad someone finally decided to ask
him which is
why didn't you fire fauci when you had
the chance
you could have done that and you didn't
and here's his reason for that
fauci um
fauci anthony fauci misled the senate
when he said that
the nih did not fund the gain of
function research
um
should you have fired fauci so a lot of
people ask me that question and i did it
right
because if you do fire him you're going
to have a firestoma on the left again as
usual
and i didn't listen to him if you think
about it
he wanted to keep our country open to
china and i closed it he wanted to keep
our country open to europe and i closed
it he talked about masks being no good
well i'm not a huge mask believer but i
think they have some purpose
and now he's a radical massacre i mean
everything he's done he's a great
promoter he's a bad pitcher he was
telling me what a great athlete he was i
said you can't throw a baseball 15 feet
i never saw that was other than
president obama it may be the worst
throw i've ever seen to home plate
no i think i did the right thing because
we would have had a firestorm less of a
firestorm now if he was hard because
he's been wrong so often but if you
think of it he wanted to keep our
country open to china europe and all
these places
and i didn't do it
okay
so you didn't do the right thing because
the left would have been mad at you
that's what he said
that's not a straw man
i'm not making a caricature of what he
said i mean that's you heard him that's
what he said
it's obviously the right thing
he says all all along he was he was
trying not to listen to fouchy he's
incompetent
so you know he's incompetent you're not
gonna listen to him but you let him stay
in that position and the reason is that
he that the left would have been mad
there would have been a firestorm
there's a firestorm every day they're
mad about everything they hate your guts
they impeached you twice
if i die they would have done it a third
time if i had fired them
maybe they would have so what
there's always a firestorm on the left
they're going to hate everything you do
especially if you're donald trump but if
you're on the right at all they're going
to hate everything you do
what kind of reasoning is this
if any other republican had said that
in any other context they were asked uh
well why didn't you do
xyz thing
if that reason was oh there'd be a
firestorm on the left
we we would they'd get killed over that
on the right
by people like me
every conservative talk show every
conservative would be killing them for
that
and trump deserves the same treatment
okay he's not special
that is cowardly stupid reasoning
i'm not surprised that there couldn't
have been a good reason
you have the ability to fire him and you
don't and then you wait until you're out
of office to complain about him
how about doing the right thing when you
have the the power to do it
of course there are many examples of
this with trump where he had the power
to do things didn't do it gets out of
office and then talks about how he
wishes those things were done
well who do you blame for that
and then
he starts talking about fouchy is bad at
throwing a baseball
how is
yes he is but how is that
this is your chance to talk about fauci
and you you spend 60 seconds talking
about his bet why is bad and 15 of those
seconds are spent on him throwing a
baseball
that's not exactly the point is it
if i were to list the top 100 things i
dislike about anthony fauci
the baseball's not making the top 100
but for trump that's like in the top
five apparently
yep the audience doesn't like it when i
when i talk about this but it's it's
it's the it's the case 2024 is going to
be here before we know it
do we want
a 78 year old trump
who doesn't do the right thing because
he's afraid of firestorms on the left
um
who you know his his last act as
president was to pardon a bunch of
rappers
and the the former uh
uh i'm blanking on his name the four
former mayor of uh i think was detroit
kilpatrick
one of the most absurdly corrupt
politicians in modern american history
corrupt to the point of of farce almost
and he's a democrat
and trump pardons him or commutes his
sentence
on his way out the door
so that's the question we get when we
get to 2024 do we want uh that
at 78 years old
or do we want
ron desantis
somebody who knows how to govern and
will govern and will make hard decisions
and doesn't give a damn about firestorms
on the left
if anything enjoys it
i mean with with uh
with desantis he's going to sign a bill
he's going to sign legislation going
after the the the biden administration
under cutting the bite administration
and and and not only is he going to do
it but he's going to go to brandon
florida to sign it
so that's that's the question
that's what's really going to come down
to
that's why i i believe look if
it is
there's no rational argument that you
can make
that trump at 78 years old would be a
more effective
leader of the country
and more effective
governor
of the country
than ron desantis
and i also don't think there's any real
argument you can make that trump would
have a better chance in the general
election than ron desantis
i think they'd both
it would be a challenge for both of them
for all the reasons why it's always a
challenge for republicans
but um i you know i i don't think that's
there's that argument but you can
certainly make an argument that trump
would walk away with the nomination in
the primary
and he would probably
that's all the more reason that i think
you know trump if he if he loves the
country
then he will step aside and and and pass
the baton around his hands endorse him
give him a a thorough passionate
endorsement
and step aside and let and let ron
desantis a much younger man
who has proven that he's able to govern
let him take the reins
if he jumps in there to keep ron
desantis out then that to me that's pure
ego that's putting ego over country
and it wouldn't it's just not acceptable
i i don't i tell you i don't take this
reason i don't take this from anybody
no none of us should
i don't do the right thing because
because the enemy would be mad not
acceptable
i would go after anybody for saying that
all right um
here's someone who actually does the
right thing in spite of a firestorm this
is a good example here joe manchin
declared over the weekend that he's
going to vote no
on biden's build back better
spending bill and here he is announcing
that on fox news
i've always said this brett if i can't
go home and explain it
to the people of west virginia i can't
vote for it
and i cannot vote to continue with this
piece of legislation i just can't
i've tried everything humanly possible i
can't get there
you're done this is this is a no
this is a no
on this legislation i have tried
everything i know to do
and the president has worked diligently
he's been wonderful to work with he
knows i've had concerns and and and the
problems i've had
i think there's a good a good
juxtaposition there um because on one
hand you have i don't want to do the
right thing because it's going to make
the left mat and here joe manchin is
he's actually is a democrat for him
it really matters uh what what the left
and what the democrats think about you
because you're on their team you're on
their side you live in their world
and it would benefit you greatly for
them to like you
as a republican president you're not
going to get the left to like you and
even if you did get some leftist like
it's not it's not really going to do
anything for you he's not going to
benefit you much
but joe manchin doing the right thing
in spite of that
so i think that this is this is that's
what real political bravery looks like
so you gotta give him credit for that
um next this is from the ap it says pope
francis doubled down saturday on his
effort to quash the old latin mass
forbidding the celebration of some
sacraments according to the ancient rite
in his latest salvo against
conservatives and traditionalists the
vatican's liturgy office issued a
document that clarified some questions
that arose after francis in july
reimposed restrictions on celebrating
the old latin mass that pope benedict
xvi had relaxed in 2007.
francis said then that he was reversing
his predecessor because benedict's
reform had become a source of division
in the church
and been exploited by catholics opposed
to the second vatican council
the vatican repeated the rationale on
saturday saying the clarifications and
new restrictions were necessary to
preserve the unity of the church and its
sacraments
archbishop arthur roche in an
introductory note said as pastors we
must not lend ourselves to sterile
polemic uh polemics
capable only of creating division in
which the ritual itself is often
exploited by ideological viewpoints
and then they went through
this clarification is really basically
it amounts to new rules they're putting
down
to clamp down in the latin mass
and all of that amounts to
trying to get rid of it
um and
you know they
of course the rationales provided are
dishonest
at best
because we're told that this is all
about unity in the church and and that's
why we don't want divisions in the
church
well part of the rules here for example
uh
one rule is that you can't have the
latin mass and um
you know the new the novus ordo the new
mass
that cannot be celebrated at the same
church
or at least you cannot have a priest who
does both
like on the same day
um
rules like that you know so while they
say that this is about unity and not
division they're actually creating more
division
in an effort to send the latin mass more
to the sidelines marginalize it
marginalize it uh make it harder and
harder to keep it going uh so so that
there's really no place for it to go and
if you want to celebrate the latin mass
you're not going to be able to find
anywhere to do it
and then to get rid of it but this is
this is devi is like a divide and
conquer kind of strategy
in the name of unity
and i know if you're not you know this
is the kind of thing it's very inside
baseball so if you're not catholic you
think what's what's the significance of
that why does it matter to me and it's
not going to affect you in your daily
life if you're not if you're not a
catholic even if you are a catholic most
catholics don't go to latin mass so
probably won't affect your daily routine
very much there there are many catholics
though who the latin masses
is crucial to them is very important to
them and their spiritual life
and so trying to take it away
and in in doing so treating them like an
enemy
will have a profound impact
but the larger theme here is that um
you know
or i guess the larger point
is that the latin mass
appeals greatly to young catholics
especially
this is something those of us who have
been to latin mass we've we've
you can't help but notice this when you
go into a latin mass you go into a
church that celebrates the latin mass
what do you find you find young families
young
large families
everywhere inside these these churches
and why is that well because
i i think for a lot of reasons number
one young people tend to be have a more
kind of revolutionary spirit
and they could take a more critical eye
to some of these things
i think maybe older people grew up with
this with what really is the new mass
and they don't really think much about
it they haven't been critical of it uh
young people have a more kind of
adventurous spirit or more or more
revolutionary in spirit
but then i also think that
younger people growing up in this
decaying empty secular society
are
just hunger for something real and true
and uh mystical you know they and
transcended
like we talked about last week
transcendence
uh
they hunger for that
because they've been deprived of it
and they find that in the latin mass
and it's bringing people in and they're
finding spiritual nourishment
and pope francis and his uh comrades
they see that as a as a problem
in fact they would rather get rid of all
those young younger people
if getting rid of latin mass means
alienating those younger families and
scaring them away is fine with him
because this is a war on tradition
when it comes down to it
really pretty horrifying
next we got let's say there were there
were protests at a school in fairfax
last week
over an alleged racist attack against a
muslim student that happened here's the
cbs affiliate talking about it
an estimated 350 students protested at
fairfax high after they say a student
was attacked here tuesday afternoon
because she's muslim she couldn't
breathe she was laid on the floor she
couldn't move out of her position
students accused the school system of
trying to sweep the instant under the
rug the school was trying to cover it up
instead i had a panic attack which that
did not happen ekron mohammed says some
students made racist drawings in a
marketing class became increasingly
aggressive and then one of them
assaulted her my backpack bumped into
him and then he got mad and he pushed me
and he grabbed my hijab mohammed says he
pulled her hijab off and when she fought
back he shoved her hard into a desk
everybody was outside waiting for the
buses and we saw the ambulance come into
the school physically my whole left side
of my body is bruised
mentally i'm okay because i have all the
support around me today muhammad says
she and the student were given the same
punishment a one-day in-school
suspension which they served wednesday
in the same room where she says the
student kept looking at her that's
entirely unacceptable and that's
something i want to go back to see with
staff how we can do better in the future
county school board member abrar omash
the only elected official in virginia
who wears a hijab says she's concerned
by the response the school system told
us it is investigating and quote no
further details can be shared at this
stage as administrators work to
establish the facts fairfax county
public schools and city of fairfax
schools support the rights of students
to peacefully protest
so there they are protesting over this
uh this hate crime and well we heard
it's a hate crime there were racial
slurs that were used um this anti-muslim
hate crime and all that
so now we get to the twist ending that
i'm sure you saw coming
from a million miles away this is from
wtop this is a city of fairfax police
department investigation has determined
that a physical altercation at fairfax
high school on tuesday
was not a hate crime according to a
press release the investigation revealed
there were no racial comments made by
either student according to police
police said that the female student
confirmed her hijab became partially
undone during the altercation exposing
her hair the female student told police
that the information posted on several
social media sites stating that racial
comments were used during altercation
were false
uh not just on social media sites but as
you as you heard the media itself has
been reporting this
nonetheless hundreds of students from
fairfax high school in virginia walked
out in protest on thursday showing their
support
for a student they say was attacked in
an islamophobic incident
the student herself is saying that's not
what happened
well she's saying that now i think
initially that that's where they got
this story but very quickly she backed
away and she said there were no racial
slurs used this what here's what it was
it was a a fight that she got into
a mutual fight as happens in high
schools uh with another student the
other student by the way not white
so these were two non-white students who
got into a fight
and during the fight her you know her uh
headdress
was was partially dislodged and it
showed a little bit of her hair
and then this story
arises
now i don't i don't know what motivated
her to come up with this version of the
story
it's not hard to come up with some
theories
maybe one of them is she didn't want to
get in trouble for being in a fight so
she so she came up with the hate crime
story instead
it seemed like a pretty
logical assumption here i don't know if
that's true or not who knows
who knows what motivates these people to
invent these kinds of stories
but we know we know generally speaking
what motivates it is that uh
is that she's growing growing up in a
world and she looks around and she sees
that
you know victimhood pays
uh victimhood gives you some points you
can cash them in you can cash in those
those tokens
in a lot of different ways
and benefit from it
get yourself out of a tight spot it's
kind of like a get out of jail free card
or maybe get out of suspension free card
here
but if you're a rational person even i i
i saw this story a couple a few days ago
when they were first walking out over
this anti this
alleged islamophobic hate crime
as soon as i saw it my first reaction
was yeah that probably didn't happen
because yet again this is this is a it's
actually it's good news it should be
good news
that this sort of thing just isn't
happening it's it's simply not happening
in the country
you're not going into a modern high
school in modern america and there are
white students tearing the hijabs off of
off of muslim girls and shouting islamic
phobic slurs at them that's not
happening
we could celebrate that because that's
that's a great thing that those these
sorts of events aren't happening
unless
you know
unless victimhood is what you crave in
which case you see that as a bad thing
one of our wonderful and unique customs
as americans is that uh we use our
garages as the the primary entry point
in the home that's what a lot of people
do it's in fact what most what most
houses do
uh but the problem is that that we also
overlook the garage even though it's
where we come and go we keep a lot of
our prized possessions there including
our cars and tools and bikes
that's why it's so common sense to know
what's going on inside the garage
introducing the myq smart camera by
chamberlain it's the only smart camera
optimized for the garage brought to you
by the leaders in garage door opener
technology with features like live video
streaming recorded events motion
detection and two-way communication
right from your phone you can make sure
your garage is secure 24 7. they also if
you pair it with the myq smart garage
control that means that you can open and
close your garage from anywhere and if
you leave you know the house and you're
worried did i remember to close the
garage just go on your phone take care
of it there it is that easy the myq
camera is easy to install and you can
quickly connect it to your phone via
bluetooth in the my queue app so what
are you waiting for give the gift of a
myq smartgarage camera to tech lovers
this season if you act now you can save
46 percent for a limited time by
entering walsh at checkout on myq dot
com welsh that's wall should check out
on myq dot com slash walls to save 46
keep an eye on what's happening in and
around your home's busiest entryway with
the myq smart garage camera it's the
only smart camera optimized for the
garage
and also
you know with all of the with gas prices
going through the roof and
inflation in the grocery store going
into the holidays i mean everything
costs more than it should that's why you
got to look to save money where you can
and here's one place where you can at
the gas pump actually with the get
upside app my listeners are making up to
25 cents for every gallon of gas every
time they fill up just download the free
get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
walsh and get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's up
to 50 cents a gallon cashback you don't
have to pay full price at the pump
anymore you can get cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
and use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents a gallon cashback on your first
tank this is free money they're trying
to give you all you have to do is say
yes and and thank you like be polite
about it also some people who drive a
lot are making up to two to three
hundred dollars a month back just just
because of the cash back on the gasoline
it is that simple that easy and that
profitable for you just download the
free get upside app and use promo code
walsh to get up to 50 cents a gallon
cashback on your first tank that's code
walsh now let's get to our comment
section
[Music]
the ghost of patrick henry says i've
been listening for years i do not have a
daily wire membership or purchase
products but the free content is great
my only gripe are the ads can you stop
running them thanks and merry christmas
i think you might be joking here a bit i
want to i want to believe that you are
but this is the attitude a lot of people
have
which is the you know they love the
content but they begrudge any attempt
that the content creators make to make
money off of that content
so i love the content keep producing it
i i really appreciate it but but but
don't don't make a living off of it at
all don't make please any attempt to
make a living off of it offends me so i
want this i want this free content i
want you to provide it for free
and um and i want to contribute nothing
at all to it
which which is i mean i understand that
attitude that's the attitude i have
about most of the stuff that i consume
online but
we might say it's a little bit of
entitlement that goes into that zach
says
matt i'm glad to hear you open you open
up about your closeted bass-headedness
it only makes me agree with your
viewpoints even more now by the way my
favorite three baits are deer crankbaits
swim jigs and last but not least frog
slash toads i don't think i've been
closeted about i think i've been pretty
open
loud and proud
um about my my self-identification as an
angler
and i love the frog baits too but it's
you know those are a little bit harder
to set the hook on so you've gotta you
gotta make sure you have the right gear
for that
uh my ex-wife says
matt i have to record myself giving a
speech for my finals and i want it to be
like one of your old videos like what in
your car i don't know if i'd recommend
that for your finals so if you can give
me some tips on how i can do that and
how to be more confident on camera the
topic of the speech is if guys gossip
more than girls
maybe you can share your thoughts on
that
if guys gossip more than girls well i
don't think that guys do gossip more
than girls in fact i'm positive that
they don't
gossiping is it's not exclusively a girl
thing but it mostly is
but here's i don't want to tell you what
to give your speech about but but here's
an interesting angle to explore
we could ask like why is it that girls
gossip so much
and i think it's actually rooted in uh
gossip itself is bad most of the time
but it's it's it's rooted in something
positive
in a positive female trait
uh positive feminine trait which is
which is empathy you know women are far
more empathetic than men
and being empathetic means that you
relate to other people you know you
really care about other people
and um
what that means is that
you know
the negative side of that is that uh
you're gonna be talking about other
people what's going on in their lives
and everything and uh
and and sometimes you'll be talking
about the positive things happening in
other people's lives and sometimes it's
gonna be the negative things that's what
that's where it's gossip but i think
it's rooted in the empathy the reason
why
men don't gossip mostly it's not because
we're
we're morally superior it's just that we
don't care that much about what's
happening in other people's lives we
just don't care that much
so i would never sit down with another
guy and spend 30 minutes oh guess would
you know what's happening with so and so
and what and then this
we just don't care it doesn't interest
us
uh because we're all a bunch of
sociopaths i guess
a t says i love how matt walsh complains
about people saying happy holidays while
also using the phrase the holidays and
happy holidays in the sponsorships that
he does way to stick with your
principals i don't complain about people
saying happy holidays in fact i think
i've i think i've said several times in
the past
that
i think the war on christmas is real i
think there are real examples of a what
you might call a war on christmas
but somebody wishing you happy holidays
that's not war on christmas
i i have in fact defended people dude i
don't get upset when i'm at the store or
something and the cashier says happy
holidays that doesn't offend me it's
fine
you know there are multiple holidays
happening in this in the season so it's
just kind of a general greeting
someone's attempting to be nice doesn't
doesn't bother me
um
let's see the duke family says matt
great show as always what the commenter
meant about catholicism and its
doctrines is that most of the doctrines
in the catholic church are unbiblical
mary papal infallibility are two of the
more notable ones as you yourself
frequently say about joe biden you can't
be catholic unless you believe it's
doctrines you're left in a tough place
there because you have an obvious
leftist pope but you're forced as a
catholic to believe he's the vicar of
christ on earth having listened to you
for some time i can say with much
certainty that you do not believe that
so you're not catholic according to your
own standards i also say i appreciate
any time you mention the bible on your
show but as a catholic you are not free
to interpret with what any passage the
bible actually means
that's up to your magisterium to
interpret for you those are both
catholic teachings and doctrines that
you will need to deal with going forward
my prayer is that you will leave the
catholic church and join a church that
believes in the true gospel not a false
gospel that rome teaches well your
assumptions about what i believe are not
accurate but i'd like to just focus on
on a basic conceptual problem here for a
second
um you say that the bible is uh is the
sole authority there shouldn't be any
doctrines outside of it and also you
lament that as catholics that as a
catholic i am not free to interpret it
as i please
and you're right about that last part
but but but here's your problem
first of all you do not interpret the
bible as you please
which is actually a good thing
because that's not how the bible's meant
to be read
okay it's not it's not it's not supposed
to be a rorschach test where it's it's
something different to everybody
um
and if you without any kind of
framework of understanding or anything
without any training without any
background knowledge without any
instruction from anybody if you picked
up the bible and tried to read it cover
to cover
you're probably going to come to all
kinds of conclusions that are incorrect
if you had no previous instruction if
nobody was telling you you know how to
interpret various parts of the bible
so but nobody really does that you know
and you didn't do that your
interpretations fall into a system
that was designed by human beings and
passed down to you nothing wrong with
that i'm just pointing it out
the idea that doctrines outside the
bible are not valid is itself a doctrine
that itself is not in the bible the
bible never says anywhere that you
shouldn't accept doctrines outside of it
also here's the big issue the bible
itself was written and compiled by
humans
right and given to you
so i'm not sure how i see how you could
accept the bible without accepting the
authority of the person who gave it to
you
you know if someone hands you a book and
says this is the word of god
it doesn't really make a lot of sense to
say oh i don't trust you you're full of
it but uh give me that book yeah sure i
believe that
what do you
based on what
if someone hands you something and you
accept it as an authority then you are
accepting the authority of the person
who handed it to you
not sure how you get around that exactly
if you didn't accept their authority
then on what basis would you come to
believe that this collection of writings
is true or meaningful or whatever
um
none of this means that the bible is not
true or the bible is not it's not the
word of god
all i'm all i'm pointing out is that god
worked through people to compile it it
was not like the bible was written in
the heavens and then literally descended
from the clouds right it was it worked
through people and so you're trying to
remove people from the equation
or the authority of people
and i'm not sure how you do that doesn't
make a lot of sense to me candace owens
doesn't hold back that's why the daily
wire sent her to mar-a-lago to interview
one of the most censored men in america
president trump where no question was
left off the table they discussed
everything from the potential for
another presidential run in 2024 to why
he didn't pardon whistleblowers and uh
what he really thinks about alec baldwin
and many other things
in fact uh you know we were just talking
about the the pardons and i have the
same question like what the people that
he chose to pardon people he chose not
to pardon and i asked candace i sent her
a message and said can you just give me
the you know we're on the same team can
you give me the spoiler what what answer
did he give and she actually told me
that i can go to dailywire.com and sign
up for a membership for 25
that's the answer i was given so i will
be watching along with you the the
interview uh was excellent and it
streams tomorrow at 9pm eastern 8 pm
central only at dailywire.com also if
you aren't aware ben shapiro just
released a new series exclusive to the
daily wire called the search the show is
a voyeuristic view of his closest and
most influential friends and him as they
share inklings and personal lives over
coffee his great friend jordan peterson
is the first to join him and it's a
truly excellent watch and a fascinating
conversation so head to dailywire.com
subscribe to get signed up you can watch
that show and also there's more deadly
wires making it easier to listen to all
of our content on the go with our launch
of listen which means you'll now be able
to listen to all of your favorite daily
wire content on the website and the dw
app listen is here to make soaking up
our content as convenient as possible
with a limited ad audio experience
whether it's catching morning wire with
a morning cup of coffee taking in the
latest hot takes from your favorite
hosts or exploring our growing radio
theater you'll get all the content you
love and if you get interrupted no
worries you can pick up right where you
left off with continue listening so go
now and uh and uh
you can listen and listen that's why
they call listen simple as that all
right let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
infamous automaton mark zuckerberg has
been working overtime to bring his
metaverse dream to fruition and he's
noticed you know that our lives have
already been almost entirely consumed by
the internet to the point where most of
us are now essentially cyborgs half
robot half human except without any of
the cool superpowers that cyborgs and
science fiction usually possess in the
movies a cyborg has all of the best
qualities of humans and machines in
reality we have the worst ingredients of
both so we're fat and lazy like people
but we're also amoral and emotionally
vacuous like computers
so we're kind of like mermaids but if
the mermaid had a fish's head and a
human's body it's like the worst
possible combination
a combination more monstrous than
mythical i guess and this is what our
near total reliance on and addiction to
the internet has done for us but mark
zuckerberg has seen all of this and
determined that we still have not
invested enough of ourselves into
cyberspace and that's where the
metaverse comes in with the metaverse we
can actually enter into the internet
submerge ourselves in it lose ourselves
inside it like a like a dream a bad
dream
if you've ever visited reddit or you've
read the comments under a viral tweet or
you scrolled through tiktok
and thought to yourself wow i wish i
could be trapped inside a
three-dimensional virtual prison cell
with these people then the metaverse
will be right up your alley but if
you're a sane person
you probably feel differently and yet it
doesn't matter how you feel this is
where we're headed
the metaverse is it's happening whether
you like it or not and 15 years from now
you'll be sitting around your virtual
dinner table
with your virtual family eating your
virtual food while your physical body is
encased in a pod and connected to wires
and tubes and you'll be telling your
virtual child who prefers to use a pep
of the pig avatar all about the old days
when the internet was contained almost
exclusively inside your phone
and peppa will laugh and say that's
silly daddy and you'll pretend to laugh
too
and nobody will be able to see you cry
because they don't have tears in the
metaverse because meta president mark
zuckerberg has declared that that
everyone must always be happy inside his
domain
anyway so the point is that that i'm not
a big fan of this whole idea but it's
happening anyway and um
and uh and though the metaverse is still
in its infancy it has already had its
first me too moment
the new york post reports it says a beta
tester beta tester has claimed that she
was virtually groped in the metaverse vr
platform horizon worlds for meta the
company formerly known as facebook meta
revealed the incident on december 1st
saying it occurred on november 26th the
woman had reported the assault
the assault
in virtual reality on the horizon
world's beta testing facebook group
sexual harassment is no joke on the
regular internet but being in vr adds
another layer that makes the event more
intense she wrote according to the verge
not only was i groped last night but
there were other people there who
supported this behavior which made me
feel isolated in the plaza the virtual
environment's central gathering space
severe encounters of online harassment
including physical threats stalking and
repeated harassment are on the rise
according to a 2020 pew research poll
with the percentage of users reporting
such incidents jumping from 15 in 2014
to 25 today while much of it takes place
on social media vr is uh still nation
and already an apparent venue for
harassment horizon worlds operated by vr
company oculus which is also owned by
meda meta is a build built as a pleasant
productive digital escape a place to
create in extraordinary ways and find
experiences that matter with your avatar
friends
groped virtually on the internet is what
we're dealing with
and
yes that's a pretty serious crime we
have to admit
in fact it brings back the trauma that i
suffered as a child when i was virtually
assaulted by a south asian man with very
long arms while playing street fighter
at another point playing a different
game i was virtually cannibalized by a
huge yellow head
i have been virtually beaten shot
stabbed tortured in all manner of ways
though i suppose i'm no saint myself in
the same game street fighter i committed
virtual battery against an obese sumo
wrestler which was arguably a hate crime
as well given that the victim was a
video game character of color but then
again my character was green so i'm not
sure how this all works uh i don't know
how we work out the intersectionality
part of that but anyway a little bit
more from the article it says in its
statement about the incident
meta pointed to its safe zone feature
which allows users to place a block
against interaction with other users
however the company admitted that it
needs to work on making the feature
trivially easy and findable
says vivek sharma the vice president of
horizon in a statement to the verge meta
spokesperson christina milion also told
mit technology review that users are
required to complete training that
covers safeguarding tools before joining
horizon world while reminders reminders
are also prompting prompted during users
experiences
sexual harassment in virtual reality is
sexual harassment in real life full stop
experts have said
quote at the end of the day the nature
of virtual reality spaces is such that
it is designed to trick the user into
thinking they are physically in a
certain space
that they're ever that their every
bodily action is occurring in a 3d
environment catherine cross a phd
student researcher on online harassment
at the university of washington told
technology review quote it's part of the
reason why emotional reactions can be
stronger in that space and why vr
triggers the same internal nervous
system and psychological responses
those who have suffered sexual
harassment in vr vr elsewhere say that
meta's safe zone feature isn't
enough okay so sexual harassment in
virtual reality is sexual harassment in
real life according to experts it's the
same
i wonder if they've
asked any actual real-life victims of
sexual assault you know people who've
had their physical bodies violated not
the bodies of cartoon characters on the
internet
how do they feel about this
do they agree that their experience was
exactly the same as the experience of
somebody whose fake metaverse avatar was
fake groped by another fake character in
a fake world
i'm guessing they'd say no
another big difference between real life
assault and virtual assault
these real victims might point out
is that the virtual victim can simply
turn off their headset
and the problem goes away
no such escape valve exists for the real
life victim they might remind us
but then again you know they aren't the
experts the experts are the experts and
we know who the experts are because they
belong to a group called the experts and
the media tells us how they feel about
stuff like this and we're supposed to
nod our heads in agreement and say
nothing else
now this is all quite ludicrous of
course by definition you cannot be
groped in virtual reality because
groping is a physical act
nothing physical is occurring in that
realm
there's a there's a reason we don't
prosecute people for vehicular homicide
based on incidents that occur in mario
kart
and yet and yet at the same time
catherine cross the phd researcher
she's correct when she says that vr
technology tricks the user into thinking
they are physically in a certain space
but the key word is tricks
it's not real
they're not actually in that space
nothing that happens to them in that
space is actually happening to them it's
happening to a computer code on a screen
so one computer code is interacting with
another computer code
it feels real but it's not
but the fact that people can be fooled
in this way
you know that doesn't mean that we need
more rules or policies or regulations
or that we have to have legal
protections put in place for cartoon
avatars
now we don't need laws that will wind up
putting 12 year olds behind bars for
first degree homicides committed in call
of duty
that's not the conclusion that we should
draw from this
here is the conclusion
that the internet is often not very good
for your brain
and virtual reality will be even worse
the fact that virtual reality tricks you
and makes it hard to distinguish between
reality and virtual reality is not an
argument for treating virtual reality
like it's reality
but it may be an argument for not using
virtual reality at all
the last thing we need is yet another
tool to tear us away from our physical
existence and immerse us in a world that
is fake but feels real
that's the last thing we need
and that's the lesson here
we don't need more virtual reality we
need we need more reality reality
that's the world we should be living in
most of the time
so that's why in the end
i think the metaverse is what we have to
cancel today
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
a swedish company wants to implant a
vaccine passport microchip into your arm
dr fauci says we'll never fly without
masks again
and west virginia senator joe manchin
derails joe biden's entire legislative
agenda check it out on the michael
knowles show